this this is all really lovely and nice
it gets there very very quickly except
it's got a teeny little problem with it
which is when you have a look at a
situation like this so this is example
one over here if you haven't already
drawn example to which I've
unceremoniously written over with my
other formulas what's the problem that's
going to present itself to you when you
have a look at this situation and you're
looking for this angle hmm
I know that someone else have a turn
area because you've been participating
so well I want you're a big hmm if I
were to look at this question and then
launch into my formula you will run into
a problem really quick smart Erica what
do you say yeah very good so Eric is
exactly right
this approach over here kind of relies
on finding what alpha and beta are and
then kind of feeding that into now note
this feeding it into town now tan is the
only one of the trig functions sine cos
etc the basic ones that has asymptotes
on and all the reciprocals have
asymptotes because that's cuz they're
reciprocals but tan has a discontinuity
at 90 degrees so therefore if you take
ten of that you've kind of in trouble
but that's alright we have another way
if you just look at the diagram we can
work this out if that's 90 raised or I
should stop saying 90 degrees by the way
we should say instead that's PI on to
okay then the angle I'm interested in is
even easier to get than all of this okay
if we call this guy alpha look at the
diagram I haven't admittedly I haven't
on the greatest job I haven't made that
triangle very large there but think
about the relationship between theta and
alpha its vertically opposite here right
both of these are theta
yeah are you okay with that you've got
this PI on two it's a really small file
two in there in the triangle so tell me
what kind of triangle that is a small
one it's a right-angled triangle so
therefore the two angles other than the
PI on to what's the relationship between
them what must they add
- they must add to that again no no no
say it again
they add two pi on two right they're
complementary okay so therefore I can
just go straight to the same theta
equals PI on two minus alpha it's the
complement okay so instead of going
through this road right where it's the
difference here I can just say I know
what this is let's actually have space
for it this time
in this case tan theta is going to be
equal to the absolute value of 10 of in
this case PI on 2 minus alpha now I went
to all the effort to point out that
they're complementary they're
complementary this feet are they
laughter and the Alpha that I can work
out through normal trig okay but
remember some of the not some half of
the trig ratios you know about are
defined by being a complementary
relationship remember that do you
remember how this sign and there's cause
which are both abbreviations right sign
which is abbreviation for sign and
because which is an abbreviation for
cosine meaning it's the complement of
sine right well we have one for tan as
well
what's the complementary identity it's
caught right like so that's that's what
it means
ko tan it's the complement of ten except
you guys would probably remember meeting
it as the reciprocal of 10 which it also
is so it's one on 10 alpha yeah so this
one is even easier than all of this
because I know what tan alpha is it's
just one of the gradients right in this
case it would be we're gonna find this
out in a second this case it would be a
half okay so my formula generally
speaking is just that there you go
that's nice right
it gave us a problem because it doesn't
work with the original one but
thankfully the replacement for it is
nice and simple so in this particular
example example two
what is our feet are going to be we're
going to get ten feet are being the
absolute value of one on a half yeah
so this is the absolute value of 2 so
what theater do you get in radians
please can I get a couple of decimal
places again it should be you know an
acute angle because I put these absolute
value signs in so I'm in the first
quadrant looks happy to me and it's of
course a smaller angle than that because
you can see we've sort of twisted this
line a bit over so it's made the English
smaller are you happy with that so I'm
gonna pop some questions up for 14a
shortly before I drew that that I want
to make one final note mrs. Lee's gave
you one out of the many reasons why when
we get to this point here here and here
I actually like to write just because
I'm kind of I don't trust myself I
actually like to write the letters are
ad just to remind myself I put that an
angle it's that's the answer and as mrs.
Lee's pointed out the symbol for radians
is a terrible symbol yeah it's mm-hmm it
looks so so just don't do it okay so I I
want I want to indicate that it's it's
that I'll write the words however just
like here and in exams and in textbooks
that kind of thing you will see it
provided without units now there are
lots of reasons why that is mrs. Lee's
already gave you one because radians are
just I just better okay but I want to
give you another one so just underneath
way you've done this can you strong for
me a little circle because it's really
nice to know all the reasons why
something is the case and it's just look
because someone decided oh I like this
rather than the other one some bits in
matter like that but most of them
mercifully are not so here's what I want
you to draw on your circle I'm gonna ask
you to draw a single Radian one Radian
in the middle of it it's gonna look
something like that roughly it's about
fifty seven point three degrees okay but
once you've drawn that I need you to
think about what a Radian actually is
what is a Radian what's what's your
definition for that okay now we haven't
done too much thinking about this so I'm
gonna try and give you the synth
definition I can and hopefully it will
explain why there's um no no units
hanging on the end here okay here's my
definition for you I'm going to draw it
and then I'm going to say it okay
there's one Radian there what makes it
one Radian is this if this is the radius
of your circle then this arc over here
subdued by one Radian is also the radius
okay let me say that again one Radian is
the angle such that the radius of your
circle is exactly the same as the length
of the arc that you get from that angle
that's what one Radian means that's its
definition okay so how does this explain
what's going on well do you remember you
did some you did some formulas with
Radian measure before right you should
have two or three in the back of your
head which is the one that connects the
radius to an arc do you remember what
the formula is l equals R theta it's one
of those beautiful simple formulas in
all of mathematics and it's a very
profound relationship right now I want
you to see what happens when we apply it
to this situation just think about it
for a second right if I say the length
of the arc is the same as the radius
then you get this ah equals R theta
right you see what's going on here now
we know because I just defined it this
way that you're going to get one but
this is what I want you to notice one
what I know this seems redundant but if
you see the relationship here right how
big does this circle what you just
actually estimate how big do you think
the radius is can you make an estimate
10 10 15 something like that okay so if
this is like 15 centimeters divided by
15 centimeters what happens to the units
they cancel right we've seen what
happens if you have like a speed or
something like that we measured that in
you know I was going 110 kilometers in
one hour so we call that kilometers per
hour that's the unit right
but here you know suppose we had a much
bigger circle suppose it was like metres
wide okay well you'd have meters divided
by meters and then again they cancel
right however big whatever size circle
you get radians are in fact not a unit
at all they're a ratio between two
identical lengths right and ratios don't
have units that's kind of the point of a
ratio a rate is comparing different
units a ratio is comparing the same ones
it doesn't have units so radians are
kind of unique in that way unlike every
other measure of size that you have in
the entire mathematics course radians
are actually what we call the
dimensionless unit they have no they
have no dimensions they're they're not
meters they're not centimeters or
anything like that and they're certainly
not degrees so that's why we don't write
the symbol that's kind of like the
philosophical reason why by the way just
to let you know the other thing that's
new since we did angle between two lines
the other thing that's new is that not
only do you know what radians are you
also know calculus now right so what
it's going to start giving you just so I
briefly look up I apologize I didn't
draw this before I should have what
you're going to get is something that
looks like this for instance they tell
you about a graph and they say here is a
straight line and they'll ask you to
find the angle between that straight
line and the acute angle with this
parabola and you're like wow how does
that work well if you're interested in
this angle here right one of the things
we know from calculus is that this
parabola at that specific point for an
INT infinitesimally small moment it
behaves exactly like it's tangent right
that's how Newton's method works it's
like well the curve isn't a straight
line but for a brief split second it
looks like a straight line okay in fact
that's what calculus is about so you can
approximate that parabola with the
tangent at that point which you couldn't
do before so you'll see in a bunch of
these questions they'll ask you not just
between the angle between two straight
lines but the angle to in a straight
line and the curve so you need to turn
that curve into a comparable
okay